Hey everybody, it's Mike from OrderFlows
here, and welcome back to my channel.
I'm glad you could join me for today's
video, where I'll be talking about uh
supply and demand in the order flow, how
to recognize it and take advantage of
it. But before we jump in, if you enjoy
learning from my videos, be sure to
subscribe to the channel, click that
notification bell so you don't miss any
new uploads. And again, you know, if you
find today's video helpful, be sure to
hit the like button for me and leave a
comment sharing your biggest takeaway. I
love hearing your feedback. And you
know, if you got a suggestion for a new
video, be sure to leave that in the
comments below.
Hopefully this weekend I can crank out
uh a bunch of videos uh based off of
your comments or to get back to your
questions. So, your support really does
go a long way in helping
um build out this channel. All right, so
let's go ahead and talk about uh today's
topic, right? Supply and demand. You
know, that's a term that we hear a lot
um you know, from traders always talking
about supply and supply and demand, and
sometimes they just I I I don't
see people just sort of draw lines on
their charts saying, "Oh, there's a
demand here, there's supply here." But
they're not really looking at the actual
trading that's taking place. So, they'll
just look at a point on a chart and say
the market turned here. Oh, you know,
there there's demand came in here. Okay.
Well, actually, on this move down,
right? This is this is where using order
flow is going to give you um some
insight that other traders don't have
because they're not looking at order
flow. Look at this, right? We are
trading
um
you know, around 7:00 just before 8:00
this morning, right? Our high in the
gold is 18 I'm sorry, our low rather,
189050.
Okay?
And you know, then we got big uh 7:45,
you know, big push down in delta down
into the new lows. Now, delta, all
right, is still positive for the day.
It's like plus 1,000 delta. Okay? Very
tight range overnight. And then we just
sort of go in sideways. And then, you
know, 8:50, start making a new low in
gold.
Okay? But you know, this was interesting
because here, right? Our delta, this is
cumulative delta on the bottom, the
bottom part of this chart is cumulative
delta. You know, it was about 1,000.
And
now we're making a new low here
at 8810,
but our cumulative delta,
you know, is like minus 1,800. We
actually saw
cumulative delta
almost double, you know, at one point it
did double, got over 2,000 here.
Um then we came into the new low, and
you know, our delta from where we were
earlier,
obviously, is is much higher. Okay?
And then, you know, delta and price,
they do sort of go along you know, in
the same direction, both
start trading higher. We trade all the
way back up to 9330, which is about
where we opened on the night before.
Delta at this point is at its
you know, kind of at its its strongest
level. All right? Then the market starts
going down, right? Price hit here,
starts going down, make a new low. Okay,
delta drops a lot in one bar.
And then it's just going sideways for
the most part here. Okay? I mean, it
does dip a little bit here to to 42, but
price keeps selling down, right? We keep
making new lows. I mean, we literally
drop from
you know, 8590
down to 74. That was a $10 move. Delta's
basically
not moving. I mean, it does go up a
little bit, comes back down,
but by the time we get to this low here,
where's delta?
2,000, right? Right you know, here.
You know, delta's positive 2,000
cumulative delta.
Okay? And you know, here we had that big
push down, you know, here was delta was
minus 1,400. Even here, where we were
earlier in the day when we just made
that new low, delta was around positive
1,000.
Now we're
you know, what is that? 90
down to 74 and a half, a $15 lower,
yet cumulative delta
is
quite strong. It's double where it was
earlier now that we're $15 lower.
All right? And even in this $10 move,
you know, we're still higher than we
were $10 ago.
Why is that, right? I mean, these are
the questions, you know, as a trader,
once you understand why it's happening,
then you can understand what's taking
place in the market, and you're going to
look for that release valve because you
can see here how delta,
you know, finally starts
jumping basically. I mean, look at this
delta here.
We're you know, at 4,000.
Right? And price has gone from 74 and a
half up to you know, the mid 80s.
Okay?
But what's taking place here?
You have supply in the market.
Right? What is supply? It's selling
pressure, right? Cuz think about you
know, people say you know, sometimes
people don't understand
really what supply and demand is. Okay?
And you know, it's not some esoteric
concept. Think about it in basic
everyday use. Okay? Say you
I don't know, you know,
say you got apples. Say you got an apple
tree, right? I went apple picking, so
I'll use apples as a uh
example.
Okay? I got a bunch of apples cuz I have
a bunch of apple trees in my backyard.
Well, I have a lot of supply this time
of year cuz it's apple season. So, what
do I got to do? I got to keep selling
them
before they s- rot basically. And what
you're seeing here is
the person with the apples lowering his
price, lowering his price, but since
it's apple season, people know that hey,
you know what? I can buy apples now for
for cheap. So, they're coming in,
they're trying to buy you know,
basically buy the apples what they think
is a cheap price cuz we're at our lows.
But there's just so much apples, the
seller's got so many apples, he keeps
offering them lower, lower, lower.
Okay? Till he gets to that point down
here
where he's got no more apples.
And now people that were thinking, "Oh
my gosh, you know, now it's apple
season, I can start buying I can buy
apples for cheap." Once they realize
that, "Oh you know what? The
guy's selling the apples,
they're they're almost sold out."
And now they're like, you know, I but
it's so cheap, I got to buy them.
Right? Now they're starting to buy it.
Right? This is what's taking place. And
if you look at the actual order flow,
let me get the footprint chart here.
Okay?
This is it, right? You can see this is
sort of go back to
that low here at 8810.
Okay?
You know, market is basically going
sideways, you know, a little bit up,
trades back up to the opening price,
starts trading back down. Okay? But as
we're going down,
right? We get you know, the few bars
with some strong selling, minus 539,
right? Then a little bit of buying, you
know, but
the key
to identifying what's taking place here,
the key to identifying that there's
supply in this market are these bars,
these red candles. They got positive
delta.
Cuz what does that mean, right? Why is a
candle going down? Just think about it
in itself, right? Just
break it down to its smallest form. I
got a candle right here, opened at 8830,
closed at 8770,
but it's got positive delta.
Well,
then you're going to start looking a
little bit deeper at the candle itself.
Okay?
You can see some decent volumes, 36, 29,
33, 25.
Okay? The volume that's trading on the
offer side
is more than what's trading on the bid
side. So, these candles
are going down,
you have aggressive sellers hitting
these bids, but what's causing this
market to not rally is supply in the
market. So, there's
there's suppliers, if you will, use that
term, suppliers, they're they're
absorbing whatever buying pressure is.
Go back to our apple example, right? We
we dip down here, people say, "Oh, you
know, 8860 even is a great price.
I got to start buying."
Okay? And they're starting to buy. But
now the apple sellers,
you know,
the the wife just pulled up to the stand
with the the pickup truck, and then they
got more apples to sell. So, people are
coming in here buying more apples,
buying more and more.
But now they got a new shipment of
apples just came from the farm.
They're selling them out, right? Because
now people are like, "Here, take my
money." And they're happy to sell.
That's why you have that positive delta.
Okay? Get down in here, you can see it's
sort of the same things um taking place,
right? Red candle, positive delta. Red
candle, positive delta.
Um and here you get some smalls.
Um
then you start seeing the aggressive
selling starting to take over in here,
right? Now you're getting the red candle
with a negative delta, negative delta,
negative delta.
Okay? And every time you sort of hit a
bottom, you know, what you think is the
bottom, and and you sort of see a little
bit of buying pressure come in, right?
The positive delta on the lows, like
here, here,
um you know, even here, right? You can
see there was
a nice point of control on the bottom
here.
It's got negative delta. So, okay, you
know, there's a big buyer down here
saying, you know,
the guy is sitting down here, you know,
I'm waiting to buy these if they get
down to
188030. So, he's sitting there with his
bid, right? He's got that resting
liquidity.
They're selling to him. Now, you know,
the apple guys are selling to the the
bidders here, right? The buyers.
And then what happens? Nothing. Doesn't
go anywhere. Next bar is a red candle
with positive delta. So, I know there's
more volume on the offer side. I know
there's still more supply
on the offer side here, just as there
was here. I even got imbalance taking
place here, 54. You know, I mean, you
see this bid here at 118.
Hey, that's a strong bid. It is.
But it's against what? 82? Right here,
you see here you see 62 and 118. Strong
volumes on the bid side.
This bar still has
positive delta. So, it's telling me that
the supply is being distributed
throughout this bar.
Okay?
Down into new lows.
Okay? Now, this is where it gets
interesting
and funky. This is how you know
that people with supply
are
not panicking, but
are realizing, "Hey, you know what? I
got to get rid of this stuff."
Red candle, red candle, red candle,
green, red, red, red. So, you got 1 2 3
4 5 6
red candles, right? You make one new
low,
two new lows, three new lows,
four new lows,
and it's all positive delta.
This market is making new lows
on positive delta.
Why?
There's too much supply, right? We When
we think about when the market's making
lows, we think of the aggressive
selling.
But you also have to think of the supply
coming into the market that is in a
sense absorbing whatever aggressive
buying there is. Cuz remember, we're
making lows.
And for the market to rally, you need
some aggressive buying.
But the the passive selling, right? The
supply
is basically absorbing whatever
aggressive buying is coming into the
market. I mean, you could see it, you
know, coming in here. 84, 67, 58. 115.
Right? Even here, 64, 103.
Right?
74, 91,
69. Strong offers that basically
absorbing whatever
aggressive buying is taking place
until that aggressive buying is
basically done. For now, at least in
that bar. Now, when we got down to this
low, this is where it really got
interesting. Because again, making these
new lows,
right? It's still positive delta. Then
you got negative delta, okay, but
positive delta, positive delta.
Now, it's starting to shift. Now, you
got a green candle with strong
um
positive delta 201. I mean, you had 205
here.
Okay? But nothing really materialized
out of it.
And I'm sort of thinking looking at it
and like, "Well, I don't know." I mean,
you
you know, you can look at you know, say,
"Oh, yeah, it's going to rally." But no,
you know, when you're looking at the
chart, you know, when you're watching it
unfold like this,
like this, and then you see the heavy
volumes coming in on the offer side,
you're still thinking of there's supply.
You see the 163, the 106, right? This
bar still got positive delta, positive
185.
Okay? And then it sort of
sells off a little bit, two ticks lower,
and then reverses and starts trading
higher. Positive delta of 235. Next bar,
80.
So, at this point, right? Now, we're
stringing together
four bars.
You know, one red candle.
But now, what we're seeing is something
slightly different. Okay? You're seeing
the green candles with positive delta,
but you're seeing the sort of the the
wider green candles.
Okay? Why is it wide? It's because now
the aggressive buyers are coming in.
But more importantly,
that supply is missing.
So, whatever supply was coming in
on this move down,
by the time you get up to, you know, the
77 area,
77, 77 and 1/2,
hopefully you should be able to
recognize, "You know what? This probably
this 163, this 106 is probably the last
of whatever aggressive or sorry,
whatever supply there was in the market
that was absorbing that aggressive
buying."
Okay? I mean, this is this sort of wraps
it up. The 163 with the 106. You don't
see any volumes like that
in here.
And so, if you can
see and make the conclusion that that
aggressive selling
or sorry, that um
Sorry, sorry, sorry. I take that back.
That supply that's coming in that's
absorbing the aggressive buying. Once
that is removed, right? Once you remove
that supply that was hanging over this
market causing it to go down,
take that out of the equation,
and you're going to be looking for the
market to rally higher.
Okay? Which it did. I mean, it got all
the way back up into the 80s up in here.
And again, you know, on this chart, you
know, this is what it looks like here.
Right now, we're sort of trading back
around What time is it now? We're about
1:00 here.
So, we're sort of back down in here.
Maybe there's some supply coming in
again later. But more importantly,
what's cumulative delta at? 3,800.
Okay?
I know that there's
strong buying at these levels. I mean,
we're we're below 1,900 bucks. I mean,
it's uh you know, I I personally think
gold at these levels is a good buy.
Just sort of on a on a macro sense. I
mean, gold is always a good buy period.
You can never own enough um
but
really the telling thing was
market selling off,
cumulative delta basically going
sideways to to higher.
Because once you, you know, cuz why is
Because you know, basically, you
if the market is selling off, right?
What do you expect cumulative delta to
be doing? You expect it to be going
lower.
Right? Cuz of the aggressive selling
that's taking place.
But if you still have aggressive buying
coming in,
but it's being met with supply,
sort of capping
any
any rally basically,
you know,
the market's going to go down.
Cuz what's what's taking place, right?
Think of it, you know, it it's Think of
it
in the 2A auction.
Right? People that follow price, follow,
you know, don't follow, whatever.
They're seeing
the price failing to go higher, right?
Even though the offer's trading. And if
you
if the offer's trading for
good volume,
and it's not going higher, then you know
you got strong sellers in that market.
Even if they're not hitting those bids
themselves, those traders that are
recognizing that there is supply in the
market, those are the traders that are
going to hit the bid.
Right? Cuz they're recognizing that,
"Hey, you know what? I'm seeing
you know, I'm seeing strong
aggressive buying coming in, right? I
got buying a balance here.
And the market's not going any higher.
That's a sign that there
sellers, the passive sellers, are
absorbing the aggressive buyers.
Okay? So,
I hope I didn't confuse anybody on this
video. I'm going to wrap it up. But you
know, it's a concept understanding
supply and demand via the footprint by
watching what the passive sellers are
doing. Because you know, when when we
think of passive buyers and passive
sellers, we think of, you know,
I know what is this in my my heat map,
right? We think of liquidity above the
market, liquidity below the market. But
when a market is going down and you're
seeing liquidity,
you know, basically, you know, offers
coming in at the current offer to
absorb whatever aggressive buying is
taking place,
that's important. Right? You got to be
able to recognize that.
I mean, it's one thing to say, "Oh,
yeah, down here at 4330, there's 240 at
29 and 1/2, there's 250." Okay, but
right now
the market's trading 35.
We're five points away from 30 and 29
and 1/2, right? You want to know what's
taking place right now.
All right, you guys, I'm going to wrap
up that video uh for now. I mean,
it should hopefully be a little bit
clearer
to you. You may for some of you guys may
have to watch this one a couple of times
to to sort of grasp it. But that's sort
of the whole concept of
understanding supply coming into the
market that's driving it down.
Um
especially when when you are able to see
cumulative delta, what cumulative delta
is doing. Cuz we're 15 bucks lower,
cumulative delta is,
you know, up near its high for the day
at that point.
Okay? Remember, I think it was last
week,
sort of the opposite was taking place.
We were
at our highs of the day, but cumulative
delta
was
negative.
All right? So, what you're seeing today
is is kind of the flip side of that.
All right, everybody. I'll end it there.
Um
I'll catch you guys on the next video.
Bye-bye.